uh
we have a lot to unpack hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be talking about
the world's obsession with celebrities
weight and giving some helpful tips on
how to complement people on things other
than weight but first let me tell you
about my sponsor obey so pre pandemic
going to different workout classes was a
major part of my life but like most
people i've really gotten to the groove
of working out at home but i still do
find it hard to stay motivated and keep
workouts interesting and fresh without
my workout gang or like an instructor
leading me through it so i was really
excited to try out obey so obey is an
at-home fitness platform that features a
huge variety of boutique fitness classes
i mean they've got 22 live classes a day
and over 7 000 onto band classes taught
by some of the best instructors in new
york city and whether you're into hit
bar sculpt yoga ride dance you name it
there is so much variety to keep things
interesting so they have classes in 5 10
15 45 and 60 minute lengths depending on
how much time you have and they have
options for folks across fitness levels
and options depending on what equipment
you have they also have curated
structured programs ranging from seven
days to 30 days for folks who need a
little more of a routine or guidance so
if you want to get started today you can
use my promo code abby month to get your
first month completely free okay but
before we get into this please see my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning as i will be talking about
weight loss so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey also don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
bell so that you never miss out on an
episode and if you don't already please
be sure to follow me on my social media
instagram tick tock all the places at
abby's kitchen so
adele's weight loss now this has been a
hot topic in pop culture and i've been
asked to talk about this weight loss a
lot and i have for the most part kind of
shied away from talking about it in
detail and that's because for the most
part adele herself has shied away from
talking about it in detail but in
october it does seem like she kind of
opened up and talked to the press about
some of the things that she did to lose
those hundred pounds so i think it's now
time we chat but not about the weight
loss specifically now i think it's
generally accepted knowledge that it's
not so nice to comment on people's
weight gain even though this happens to
celebrities every single day but on the
flip side i think it's generally seen as
a nice thing to do to compliment someone
on their recent weight loss even when
said weight loss is done privately now
when adele lost a substantial 100 pounds
over the past year or so she did so for
the most part quietly behind closed
doors probably because i don't know most
of us were stuck behind closed doors in
the midst of a global pandemic but what
thrust her again into the spotlight was
her may 2021 birthday post to me
she looked beautiful and happy and she's
always looked beautiful and happy but
for whatever reason the world lost their
now interestingly up until october of
this year when i started to see a few
interviews kind of come out where she
discussed what she did to lose weight
she was pretty silent about the whole
ordeal unlike most celebrities who
undergo major weight transformations she
did not document her weight loss she
didn't share frequent before and after
photos she didn't book an endorsement
deal with weight watchers or jenny craig
or some detox company and she didn't
purposefully post a big reveal of her
new body i don't know about you but i
would say that these are all pretty good
clues that she didn't really want to
talk about it until of course she did so
why the hell are we so intent on talking
about it and talking about it a lot from
the popularity of shows like the biggest
loser and the swan to classic makeover
scenes in every 90s rom-com ever made
let's do a makeover people
love to see the larger body person lose
weight or suddenly get hot
and i say person but really i'm
predominantly talking about women though
as the recent headlines from jonah hill
begging the public to stop commenting on
his weight reveal men are also
not immune now in the case of adele like
lizzo she's often being appointed the
role of like the poster child of the fat
liberation or body positive movement a
role that arguably she didn't choose
herself now i've talked about this in my
video on the backlash to lizzo losing
weight or doing a detox and i would
argue that there's been some unfair
criticism from fans who praised her for
that role being angry at someone for
losing weight is just as problematic and
oppressive as criticizing them for being
bigger or for gaining weight it still
objectifies women and it robs them of
their own body autonomy and actually it
detracts from the purpose of the body
positivity movement if we support body
positivity and equality we should be
talking about these women for their
musical talent period not disappointed
when their body size changes assuming it
doesn't like change said talent period
in today's video i actually want to talk
about body praise and the power of our
words when it comes to talking about
public weight loss now if your knee jerk
reaction to me suggesting that
complimenting someone on something that
is so obviously good is potentially
problematic you need to listen to this
video
more than anyone you listen to me
because you love me i'm not trying to be
harsh or call you out if this is like a
common topic of conversation in your
circles but i am hoping that this video
may offer a new perspective and maybe
trigger some introspection on your own
deep seated beliefs about good and bad
bodies there are a number of reasons why
simply complimenting somebody on their
body is problematic even if it's done in
good faith first of all complimenting a
woman on her weight loss reinforces the
potentially dangerous binary that weight
loss equals good and weight gain equals
bad it then follows that a woman's body
getting smaller is almost always a
positive thing especially if that person
was previously in a larger body now even
if a celebrity or normal person like me
were to gain a few pounds during covet
or the holidays even if their weight
didn't change their health status at all
we typically don't see a big fuss and if
anything is said it's probably not super
nice and everybody knows this yes i
realized that there are exceptions to
this like when a so-called or seemingly
emaciated celebrity seems to gain weight
back and there's like media coverage of
that but by and large
the fanfare is loudest when a fat
celebrity
gets thin and that's possibly because
the world inaccurately conflates a lower
body weight with better health for folks
struggling with complicated relationship
with food this dichotomous thinking
reinforces the narrative that everyone
is thinking and talking about people's
weight like if a stranger is talking
about adele's shrinking body then of
course our friends and coworkers must be
thinking about our body too and this can
perpetuate disordered eating behaviors
body dysmorphia and black and white
thinking about food and exercise second
these comments assume that once weight
loss is intentional since socially we
are almost always trying to actively
lose weight like it seems rare to
publicly discuss intentional weight gain
outside of maybe the niche bodybuilding
world even though trust me it is a
common enough desire but the reality is
weight loss isn't always intentional and
it sometimes can be a sign that
something is like very very wrong i know
in my early eating disorder days i
actually never meant to actively lose
weight i was actually trying to fix a
digestive problem by removing a bunch of
triggering foods and it was people's
initial comments about me looking good
and losing weight that triggered me to
kind of tighten the reins even more and
that of course caused me to spiral into
a very dark dangerous place now in the
case of adele i don't know and i really
don't care what her intentions are but i
did see her quoted as suggesting that
weight loss was never her explicit goal
but that she was just kind of using
exercise as an anxiety management tool
and she quote unquote got addicted i am
not going to pathologize that statement
because again i don't know her i don't
know what's healthy or unhealthy
to her but i do think it's enough
information to suggest that she was
never inviting or requesting this
feedback into her life her changed body
was potentially something that kind of
happened to her as a side effect of a
stressful year and we all had a
stressful year so if she wasn't talking
about it why should we so complimenting
somebody on their weight loss could
inadvertently be complimenting them on
disease on heartbreak on a mental health
struggle etc it's just not appropriate
now finally these comments insinuate
that like the shape and size of our
bodies are
the most important and interesting thing
about us and it communicates that your
value as a person is contingent on
maintaining the improvements that you've
made to your body like even a
musical genius like adele who is
ferociously talented is talked about
more for her body than for her voice
[Applause]
like that is 50 shades of [ __ ] up so
i know
we are in the holiday season and these
situations might come up and i really
want to highlight some
innocent comments that might be
triggering to some people and these are
people that you care about so for one
saying things like wow you look like
you've lost weight or like asking
somebody for their weight loss secret
this to me speaks for itself because of
all the reasons we just discussed and in
the event that you don't know how they
lost weight please do not comment and do
not ask if you're close enough to
discuss these matters and maybe you want
to check in with them because you're
worried about their well-being then ask
them how they're doing like ask them if
they're emotionally okay ask them how
they're feeling but do not make it
automatically about the weight another
thing to be mindful of is like the er
words the er words so
prettier skinnier thinner are obviously
more problematic er words but even
telling somebody that they look
healthier can be a little bit sensitive
it's kind of become the pc word for
skinnier since again we often conflate
weight with health but for folks with
complicated histories with their body
it's really easy to decode this and
again it can be triggering so it
insinuates that you didn't look good
before which obviously feels like your
body is being surveillanced and judged
and that doesn't feel good
and i know that most of this
conversation has really centered around
weight loss comments but this actually
also goes for situations where maybe
friends were perhaps looking kind of
like too skinny by society standards in
the past and have since gained weight it
is really easy for someone's disordered
eating voice to interpret you look
healthier to you look fat and then for
them to undo any progress towards better
mental or physical health that maybe
they have made this definitely happened
to me at points in my recovery and i
really wish that people would have maybe
talked about something else other than
my body again it just made me feel like
everyone was watching and talking about
it and that my whole identity was
wrapped up in my body so i think it's
just best not to compare a body today
with a body from the past also
commenting on clothes i would say is
actually a bit of a tricky one so i
think it's always nice to hear someone
say i love your shirt or i love your
purse or your shoes or whatever but it
gets sticky when the context is how the
clothing is making your body look
[Music]
so this may seem like a workaround that
makes it okay because you're not talking
directly about the body but calling
something slimming or flattering also
insinuates that the natural body is
not so great but the right clothes can
fix the problem again it's just not
really appropriate basically if you're
unsure if something that you're about to
say is potentially objectifying or like
non-consensual ask yourself if the
compliment would make any sense if you
removed the body from the equation would
it even make sense if their body were to
change back or if it had not changed at
all so if it loses its meaning it could
be objectifying and potentially
unwelcome and might do more damage than
good also big fyi no one including
myself can expect perfection of
themselves here we are all going to make
these comments sometimes because we've
been taught it's a nice thing to do like
i still catch myself telling my
postpartum or my pregnant friends that
their body looks great and it's like i
cringe as the words just slip out of my
mouth but it's just so deeply ingrained
as the thing to do so there is just
obviously a lot of unlearning that we
all have to do and it really does take a
lot of time so please do cut yourself
some slack ultimately though i think
there's a lot more interesting things
about people than their weight and while
we may see celebrities as god-like
figures like undeserving of respect they
are in fact just people and if we want
to see a change in our everyday
conversations we need to enable a change
in pop culture too so adele you can lose
weight gain weight with intent or by
accident as long as you can continue to
sing like this
[Music]
i am a forever fan i mean unless you
become the new face of tummy tea then we
need to talk and on that note i am going
to spend the next hour in the bath with
a glass of wine listening to easy on me
on repeat getting angsty about the
breakups that i never had change your
relationship status to make it official
but that is all that i have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who you'd like to see review
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
you